oh my god can't get it off me get off me
[Music]
I'm absolutely petrified of birds I hate
pigeon seagulls and geese geese will you
over seagulls don't give up and then
pigeons are just like reckless [ __ ] I
think rats are pretty gross just to
carry disease and just I'm not into them
recently I found a mouse in my house I
didn't eat in my house for a full week I
picked a snake if you're kind of started
with my mom because my mom is absolutely
terrified of snakes and as it turns out
if you're like raised like that you're
gonna become scared of snakes too I
picked the black-throated monitor as one
of my biggest fears because it's a large
reptile that has super dry skin and
seeing that freaks me out and also just
the bite that they have is it's
terrifying the way lizards and reptiles
move around it just is not natural I
just heard a rumor that this snake is
poisonous and no one will tell me if
that's true a melted this this morning
they said they'd milk it every day so
that there's no poison they milk the
snake Fernando has this like
Shakespearean drama that's been going on
with the entire rodent population of Los
Angeles you're gonna see the picture of
the RET that I killed wait how are you
have it on your phone I'm not someone
who's typically open about what I'm
afraid of and it feels really vulnerable
to be put in a position with people like
seeing you scared I'm gonna power
through I'm gonna try to get through
this and not make a lot of noise I
scream and I'm also nervous about having
my scream on camera because I scream
like an elderly woman the best-case
scenario is the bird doesn't poop on me
and I get a cute Instagram best-case
scenario I get a cool-ass photo and me
and the rat actually become good friends
well here's the thing I respect animals
but when they get in my house and they
poop on my table where I have dinner
that's like a whole different thing I
think I'm gonna do okay the worst thing
that could happen today is that I die in
in the end we're all gonna die so once
you get over that it's all right my name
is Daniel I'm from there critter Squad
so the critter Squad is like a specialty
zoo we visit after-school programs and
different events and we do educational
presentations so the snake I have today
is a red tail boa he's a juvenile so if
he is gonna get close to double in size
he's a constrictor so those snakes are
snakes that capture their prey with
their mouths and wrap
on them and squeeze them and then
swallow them home right before the snake
came in I said just pretend that you're
wearing the world's worst scarf if I say
to take it off you'll take it off of me
yeah medially okay
oh my god oh my god can't get it off me
you know Meritor oh my god keep it off
yeah yeah oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my what we're doing
honestly scared shitless is a really
good look on Stephen so he pulled it off
it was a couple of pictures in oh yeah
yeah yeah he got the hang of it and the
more he got into it the more confident I
think he got really cool I want to try
again just like yeah I'm good it just in
that moment it seemed to really get some
attitude it got a lot better as it went
on and like towards the end of it I
definitely got more comfortable with it
I didn't cry and I didn't even hold back
tears I didn't have to the bird his name
is Bobby Bobby is a jacobim pigeon they
were bred out just to have beautiful
feathers and that's the only purpose of
them actually they inhibit their ability
to fly so if Bobby were to go up he
would just fly in a circle and come back
down so that makes them really good pets
I am being warned that the bird might
flap its wings or fly away in the middle
of a shoot the main concern that I have
going through my head is staying
composed and not freaking the bird out
because I know birds can be really
skittish and I was just trying to stay
calm I'm dying because the bird just
looks cute to me but I can see in Sam's
eyes that he's getting freaked out I'm
just acting like I'm getting a shot at
the doctor's office I'm looking away and
just pretending that nothing bad is
happening
there's a bird flying around up there
Here I am NOT doing this that is
terrifying honestly if that thing never
came back I would not feel sorry to
float over my head and I just hear it
crash it hit a light no I did have the
birds fine I'm experiencing every
emotion possible right now I use an axe
so the lizard I have today her name is
Miss Daisy and she's at a GU they're
omnivores so they're gonna eat anything
from fruits and vegetables and of course
wheat she has cute chubby cheeks but in
reality it's a lot of muscle and her
bite rink is quite strong oh no its face
is monstrous with sorry I'm not gonna
curse but holy that looks like a demon
Wow okay so this is Daisy it's not as
big as I thought it was I'm just more
concerned with its face she freaked me
out at first her face is just like
actually a me and it feels like a
monster is coming at you so you could
hold her like you know in front of you
she likes to be held up against like a
good body like a baby would so just get
more support she's a little if she loves
the way I taste cuz she keeps trying
okay oh I just hurt tongue okay I feel
like Daisy was kind of into Ryan Joe we
were told that she was tasting him
I put my hand on her tail and I felt it
underneath me and I like run because I
thought she was gonna freak out I'm just
waiting for her to hiss at me the rat
her name is Oreo rats get a bad rap it's
really just because were youth fine rats
in reality rats were really nice and
they're pretty smart as well the worst
part is that she was trying to whisper
things in my ear and I was not about
that Fernando is dealing with this very
crazy rat and it's all over this rat
likes to move it's really hard to post
with the rat on your face
go figure it's biting me it's biting me
people here don't want to admit it but I
know she bit me and I feel like
everybody's in denial because it didn't
want me to freak out did the rat bite
Fernando is he being dramatic are you
accusing a gay man lying and being
overly that rat bit me twice not upset
about it I'm not gonna confront her it's
all good if this was America's Next Top
Model I've definitely be expecting my
elimination
I'm like so excited to see these
pictures right now if nothing else we
conquer our fears we're better people
for it
see you were like serving looks I was
scared out of my mind so I have no idea
if this is gonna look remotely modely at
all but I'm excited to find out are you
a changed person after this experience
howdy
wait so the first photo that I have is
Stevens Oakland yours
if I saw this picture with no context
not knowing you I would be like Oh
Stevens serving face and he's not going
home this week on America's Next Top
Model I'm so proud of you you can see
I'm like barely touching it but I do
think it work next up we have Sam oh wow
there's not a trace of fear in it you're
just very much like I'm here I'm here to
serve face oh this bird she's just my
sister it's fine we're living we're
getting life it looks so so good and
also I love the Sheerness of the shirt
the nipple is probably my favorite part
all right guys we have Ryan you were
like the faith of like target a
nationwide campaign there's so much like
joy and light and positive energy which
is so crazy to me because you pick
something that you're terrified of and
yet you were able to bring out this
really like sunshiny vibe I love it I'm
jealous all right I'm next
it's honestly perfect like your body
composition that energy in your face it
looks so good and I'm surprised they got
pictures of that right standing still
but I didn't think you were gonna be
able to serve looks because you're not
serving but here we go after posting
with the rat I paint them a little bit
less
should we go to Petco and get you a
little rat you know what it's good for
now I think I'm fine one step at a time
[Music]